you just don't believe what is going on
even if you read it in the papers you
just don't believe what is going on in
the libraries even if you see it on the
news you just don't believe what is
going on in the schools
drag queens and stilettos get to dance
around for toddlers Kirk Cameron doesn't
get to read a nice book about family but
that is going on and it's so much worse
than that James O'Keefe at project
Veritas has just come out with an expose
man named Joseph Bruno Joseph Bruno dean
of students at Francis W Parker school
this is in Chicago the Francis W Parker
school is a private school that goes all
the way up to 12th grade goes all the
way down to pre-k and here is what Dean
Bruno had to say about his lesson plans
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using blue versus using
spit meet Joe Bruno dean of students at
the prestigious Francis W Parker private
school in Chicago which happens to
charge forty thousand dollars per
student they're just like passing around
dildos butt plugs the kids are just
playing with them they're like how do
you how does this book work how do I do
like how does this work that's a really
like a little part of my job parents
might be stunned to learn that Bruno's
version of love and acceptance means
handing out sex toys to underage
students
that's a really cool part of his job you
know that's the really cool part
what's so devastating about this clip is
one it's more obscene even than I would
expect and my head is in the news all
day long it is very hard to shock me
with anything going on in our schools
and and wherever these radicals reign
the private school
this is a school that parents pay forty
thousand dollars for this is this is
what happens when you look at the public
schools and you say man the public
schools are so bad they're so crazy
they're filling our kids heads with such
nonsense especially in Chicago okay I'm
gonna take this big Financial hit I'm
going to pay a full College tuition
every single year pre-k through grade 12
to send my kid to this private school so
that he can be
groomed into weird creepy sex stuff from
a very very young age while the dean of
students is Giddy and bragging about it
that's how bad
it is and we don't believe it because
we we're always about five years behind
we conservatives
we don't we're always kind of fighting
the last battle and the libs have moved
on and it just kind of breaks our brains
even listening to that my brain just
kind of breaks I think I can't what does
he really mean what is he really saying
he can't possibly mean that that is what
he means that is what he is doing now
the good news is conservatives are
winning a little bit
at pushing back on some of the woke
stuff we're not really winning in the
schools all that well we're not really
winning in the media all that well we're
not really winning at The Ballot Box
these days all that well we are winning
on one front though and that would be
the ESG agenda we are winning on the
investor side of things you've heard
about ESG that's the environmental
social and governance policies that are
is just a kind of woke Smorgasbord of
policies that major asset managers uh
demand that the companies that they
invest in start to put into effect the
example that I keep using
is that Cracker Barrel the other day I
was driving past the sign for Cracker
Barrel and it said come try our new
vegetarian sausage it's the impossible
sausage it doesn't have any meat in it
and I thought
wow ESG is real because the vegetarian
sausage at Cracker Barrel is obviously
not in response to any consumer demand
it's not in response to Market forces
not one single vegetarian has ever
walked into Cracker Barrel not once okay
this is obviously in response to some
woke Looney Tune calling them up from
the asset managers and saying hey
you need to wokeify your menu
so what did I do I Googled I said who
are the investors in Cracker Barrel and
what do you know I forget who was number
one and who was number two and who was
number three but it was Black Rock
Vanguard State streets all these guys
that are the the big asset managers who
are pushing this so really good news
Vanguard is pulling out of the zero Net
Zero asset managers initiative
Net Zero asset managers initiative is
one of these far left environmentalist
policies being pushed in our economy
Vanguard which is one of the three
biggest asset managers is is pulling out
of that why is Vanguard pulling out
Vanguard says it's going to withdraw to
quote provide the clarity our investors
desire about the role of index funds and
about how we think about material risks
including climate related risks okay
kind of a bland statement well you know
we just want to provide some more
clarity on how we're using our investors
money yeah okay who are the investors
though is Vanguard doing that because
you or I maybe have some money in
Vanguard or our retirement accounts or
somehow tied to Vanguard or not really
the reason why Vanguard is doing this is
because states are pulling their money
from these woke funds
it wouldn't be enough if it were just me
and you it wouldn't be enough if it were
the entire daily wire daily wire has a
million members and we have many
millions of readers and listeners across
all of our shows and website we've got a
million active members who are paying a
bunch of money to support the daily wire
program very much on board if every
single one of us called up Vanguard
tomorrow and said pull your money from
these woke initiatives Vanguard would
laugh at us okay that's not enough but
what did happen it wasn't just
some group of people some Community even
a big company like the daily wire the
state of Texas called okay the state of
Texas announced
that they are pulling out of the these
these woke asset managers people like
Vanguard State Street BlackRock you've
seen similar moves from Red States all
around the country
and we've been reporting on this for
about six months now this is key and I
hope that conservatives learn the lesson
the lesson here is
that what fixed this problem or what is
starting to fix this problem is not the
market it's not the free exchange of
ideas and goods and services what fit is
fixing this problem right now is
wielding political power what is fixing
this problem right now is the heavy hand
of the state okay people electing
Republicans putting them into office as
state treasurers and similar offices and
then those State treasurers punishing
these companies and saying you jerks if
you keep using investor money to both
retail investors and big institutional
investors big state investors like us we
are going to punish you and we're gonna
pull our money out we don't give a damn
what your returns are we're gonna pull
it out because we don't want you pushing
your weird creepy leftist policies and
what happens
the asset managers blank
that's a very very good thing
conservatives used to understand how to
build political power they haven't in
the last couple of decades 10 20 years
ago you would have heard the
conservatives say well it's that's not
right that's fascism if the if the state
treasurers call the asset managers and
say don't trans the kids and get rid of
all of the food that we like and upend
our way of life that's that's fascism
it's authoritarian you can we we can't
ever stop the left from controlling our
corporations yet no we can't oh yeah
that's called self-government okay
that's that's why we elect these people
in the first place
is to put the will of the people within
the bounds of law and the Constitution
into effect
we're not going to make an idol out of
environmentalism we're not going to make
an idol out of the weird sex stuff we're
not even going to make an idol out of
the free market this ideal that doesn't
actually exist in practice we are going
to say hey politicians put your
constituents first and and represent our
views because we are supposed to live in
a self-governing republic
and by golly we're going to keep trying
to live in one as long as we possibly
can the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]